what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like we know what what if
season two is going to be about as we
have descriptions and possibly titles
revealed for the Nine episodes of what
if season two some of these are really
cool and some of these might surprise
you and some of these will just make you
wonder why but that is the point of what
if to ask what if crazy things happened
or not so crazy things sometimes just
the slightest change in an event could
have drastic changes for the future so
we'll go over what each episode is going
to be about to the best of our knowledge
and you can let us know if you're
excited about any of these as we go
through them and right away let us know
did you like season one of what if many
of you know my personal opinion on what
if but I'd love to hear from the fandom
what did you all think of season one of
what if did you like it did you not was
it meh let me know your thoughts and if
you're looking to enter our giveaway all
you have to do is subscribe and leave
comments on our video that automatically
enters you for a chance to want to Xbox
series X A PS5 so Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of every single month so we're going to
start with one and this doesn't
necessarily mean that this is going to
be episode one we do not know the
episode orders we just know what certain
episodes are going to be about so we'll
talk about nine different episodes this
is what they're going to be about but we
do not know the order of their release
now I've seen several lists posted
online so far they're all the same
incredible insiders have backed up that
yes this is what these episodes are
going to be about I believe the list was
first posted by the nerd rage podcast
stating that the what if episodes have
been revealed and in response to this
list can we get some toast the credible
Insider stated not the actual titles
more like short descriptions besides the
happy saving Christmas one that they
already shared they also added that
strange Supreme will make his return in
one of these episodes and they left a
little note that one of those is an
accurate listed what if one and Peter
watched musicals instead of sitcoms is
not one so that one's on the list but
according to can we get some toast it's
not an actual episode so we're gonna
skip over that one but the first one on
this list is what if Gamora killed
Thanos now this would obviously be huge
and it would affect many different
things now we're not sure at what point
in time Gamora would have killed Thanos
but think about the first Guardians of
the Galaxy film Thanos played a really
decent role in that film he was in it
for a bit and his role in it was quite
important he was the reason that Ronan
was searching for the Power Stone so if
Gamora would have killed Thanos before
this then that means the events of
Guardians of the Galaxy wouldn't have
happened which means we wouldn't have
our Guardians of the Galaxy in the MCU
so that would have been really really
big that plus we wouldn't have any of
the events that follow Guardians of the
Galaxy we wouldn't have Avengers
Infinity War we wouldn't have Avengers
endgame and we've known since the very
first Avengers film that Thanos was
going around trying to collect the
stones well he wouldn't have been going
around trying to get the stones so this
would affect a lot of different events
and really the MCU would be completely
different so I'm curious to see when
Gamora killed Thanos in this what if
Episode another one is what if Captain
Carter finds the Hydra stomper and this
is interesting because it appears that
this one is going to be continued from
season one and I personally did actually
enjoy this episode I enjoyed watching
Captain Carter get the super soldier
serum I enjoyed watching Steve Rogers
get an Iron Man suit of some sort from
Howard Stark I actually did really enjoy
the story and I didn't enjoy most of
what if to be honest but that was an
episode I enjoyed so I'm looking forward
to seeing kind of a continuation of that
the next one is what if the Tesseract
landed in hadanasani Confederacy before
the colonization of America this is
going to be an introduction of a new
hero kahori now we actually have a
picture of the character and we actually
know a little bit about her hori is a
young Native American woman of Mohawk
descent and her day view episode will
revolve around what if exploring what we
just mentioned what would happen if the
Tesseract landed in The Sovereign
Confederacy before the colonization of
America and when the Tesseract lands it
transforms a portal into space that
enables young kahori to begin a journey
to discover her power that's what we've
been told about this episode the episode
is written by Ryan little who worked
closely with the people of the Mohawk
Nation on the character and the story
those people included Mohawk language
expert Cecilia King and historian Doug
George who really ensured there is
cultural authenticity to the character
of kohori the other elements featured in
her episode which is really cool details
like her name originating from the
Mohawk wolf Clan and meaning she who
stirs the forest are cleverly woven into
the story as she will recruit those
around her and stir them into action to
fight for her people and forever alter
the course of history so I think that
one's going to be pretty exciting and
with the Multiverse now happening who
knows maybe she could jump into live
action that would be really cool to see
the next is what if Hank Pym and Janet
Van Dyne fought the Red Guardian during
the 1980s and that'll be pretty
interesting a crazy super soldier who
wants to be Captain America fighting
Ant-Man and the WASP the original ones
that could be some pretty cool action to
see also another interesting one is what
if yondu delivered Star-Lord to Ego if
you recall at the end of Guardians of
the Galaxy the first film you might
remember yondu and craglin talking
saying that it was probably a good thing
that they never delivered him to his dad
like they were hired to do of course in
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 we would
go on to find out that ego was his dad
and we know that ego essentially needed
Star-Lord to be a battery for him so he
and his powers could essentially take
over the entire universe now if yondu
would have delivered a young Peter Quill
to him perhaps Peter would have been
more easily influenced and perhaps
fascinated that his father was a god
with a small G as ego puts it so perhaps
ego could have actually convinced a
young Peter Quill to help him and could
have possibly raised him to eventually
go on to take over the universe and
perhaps Peter being young and listening
to his father could have started to go
along with it who knows but it will be
an interesting episode to watch the next
one we already knew about and it's going
to be a Christmas episode and it is what
if happy Hogan Saved Christmas and
apparently this might tie into Iron Man
3 although we're not sure about that one
yet we're not all too sure what this
episode will entail however we do love
the character happy Hogan and it was
pretty funny when we saw him in the
first season of what if so we're
expecting a great episode here and the
last two are super interesting I can't
wait to see these what if Odin and hella
faced winwoo well one seeing Odin and
hella two incredibly powerful Gods fight
together is just going to be great to
see but seeing them fight winwoo AKA The
Mandarin with the 10 Rings is going to
be pretty interesting one would think
that Odin and hella shouldn't really
have a problem with winwoo but who knows
maybe we haven't seen how strong the tin
Rings could actually be maybe Xiang Chi
was just a little bit of a taste a
sampler regardless I can't wait for this
episode and the last one sounds pretty
cool as well what if the Avengers had
fought certain now we did see sir tur
and Thor Ragnarok he kind of saved the
day at the end of Thor Ragnarok he
defeated hella but also destroyed Asgard
but asgard's a people not a place I'm
curious to see what situation The
Avengers will be put in to actually have
to go up and face serveter will they
simply help Thor maybe save Asgard
before it falls the Searcher go on in
some point in the MCU to cause more
chaos does he manage to get away from
Asgard after he destroys it because we
know that you can't stop certer before
the events of Ragnarok because he has to
destroy Asgard in order to defeat hella
unless the Avengers are going to fight
hella too but that's not really what it
says so this will be interesting to see
how it plays out and to see what events
kind of happened before and after the
Avengers fight Searcher and that is what
we know about the new episodes coming
and what if season two some of them
sound cool some sound okay but go ahead
and let us know what you think about
these in the comments down below do you
have one that you are most excited to
see and do you have one that you will
not watch let us know all of your
thoughts in the comments please don't
forget to like the video and of course
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the MCU you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof
foreign